[Applause]
this was always going to be a day of
trouble seven anti-government protest
rallies across Hong Kong and no end of
splinter demos full of young men and
women eager for the fight in Kowloon the
police made it clear from the start
there was no room for compromise
[Music]
[Music]
round after round fired at protesters
from disjunction tacitly though the
police were in a bad position they were
surrounded
the protesters have upped the ante now
after nine weeks they have tactics as
well behind the umbrellas they slowly
but surely move forward
while other groups attack the police
from different directions every few
minutes the streets filled with tear gas
but the protesters return fire throwing
smashed bricks and teargas canisters
back at the police
[Applause]
then a charge fooled the protesters
ignoring rubber bullets and gas
canisters
they loved stones at the police who are
now retreating it was clear they were
losing this confrontation the protesters
pushed on
[Music]
we were forced to the side of the road
surrounded by the rioters right behind
us as well
tear gas rounds and stones can hemmed us
in while the riot continued pandemonium
now because the police have absolutely
totally lost control of the street
protesters of pile down and they're
messing up buildings here this is a way
way out of control much worse than we've
seen before by now the police had
retreated into an officer's
accommodation block the protesters
immediately started throwing rocks into
the compound
any returned tear gas fire that failed
to get over the wall was greeted with a
cheer Sun began smashing traffic lights
while others prepared for more trouble
there has been violence across Hong Kong
more demonstrations are planned more
confrontation will happen but this has
changed things the police
lost here it's hard to imagine there
won't be a reaction stir on Zee Sky News
Hong Kong